in addition to that atlas we have we
also have a very large and very complex
data file this data file represents how
the Atlas should be rendered to draw the
entire map now this is a pretty complex
file because it's actually been
generated by an external tool called
tiled prior to running the game an
artist would take our atlas data and the
tiled tool for grits we actually read
the exported json data into our game
which tells us how to render the images
and the tiles on the screen now in order
to actually render our map we need to
parse the exported data file that we've
been given from the tiled editor the
data that we extract from this will tell
us a number of things first off what
Atlas is to load and secondly how the
layers are organized given to us by the
artist for example you can see that the
data layer here actually references what
tiles to render as well as the height
and the name of the layer itself we'll
need to be able to scrape all this and
properly understand how it's laid out to
render our final image